irgendwie sieht vor die so aus als würde
er hilfe brauchen
anja forkel braucht hilfe das stück
plastikbesteck mit dem wir schon den
ganzen tag geredet ja ich glaube das
braucht hilfe sonst braucht hier niemand
hilfe auf gar keinen fall
heute herzukommen zur neuen video ich
bin wieder zurück aus dem urlaub ich
habe meiner familie partner in den
teilen bin jetzt wieder da für euch in
deutschland und bin zurück mit einem
neuen video denn selbst beständig
standen youtube mühlen nicht still als
ich im ausland unterwegs war und es ist
einiges passiert was ein bisschen
aufarbeitung braucht unter anderem ist
passiert dass rebecca wing den ford
trennt jetzt tatsächlich für sich
genutzt hat und jetzt nur noch videos
darüber macht er deutlich vor einer
woche wieder aufladen wo ich das erste
video von dem bergring reagiert habe wo
sie also ja mit diesem gipfel also diese
plastikbesteck facetime oder bing hat
gedacht wurde
das reicht natürlich noch nicht aus wir
müssen ein bisschen mehr machen und hat
sich dann entschieden einen tag lang
dieses stück besteck zu starten
sie stockten objekte ich bin so wie ich
bin wieder da mit einem neuen 24 stunden
video und arbeitet ihr alle das sehen
ich habe gar keine ahnung warum
und zwar wolltet ihr alle sehen wie ich
einen nicht lebendigen aus plastik
gegossen entgegen stand der zur essens
auf nahme gedacht ist ok aber okay ich
war ja auch drauf und dran ist einfach
nur weg zu werfen und das die rede von
fortuna ihr wollt dass ich ein tag mit
hockey verbringen ok also das ist ja mal
das was in diesem jahr passiert im
rebecca ring wird jetzt diesen dieses
stück plastik versteckt was jetzt gerade
in der hand hält mit zu müssen
pfeifen reiniger draht außen dran
stocken für 24 stunden auf ist er ja ich
meine dass er die naheliegendste sache
also was mein nächstes video klar
natürlich stark ich ein stück plastik
wir werden den ganzen tag lang auch
fortis toppen
also wir müssen wirklich mal uns vor
augen halten wir dürfen das nicht so
einfach so akzeptieren ich meine
mittlerweile haben wir uns bis mitte
wedding auseinandergesetzt und so und
wir haben die eine oder andere ja
wahnsinnig kite können fast sagen schon
gesehen was aber nicht heißt dass wir
akzeptieren sollten dass das normale ist
okay also wir lassen uns noch mal auf
der zunge zergehen rebecca ringst ort
jetzt plastikbesteck man wird dafür
einfach so von ihren fans oder
kommentare gepostet und ende 2016 killer
clown 2017 momo 2018 chef annabelle game
master 2009/10 gabel
ja ich werde jetzt erstmal für sehen und
wir werden jetzt und zwar zum
frühstücken machen und foxi kann mir
dabei zugucken ich werde ich glaube ich
nicht benutzen ok also dieses wieder
fängt jetzt tatsächlich damit alle der
content partner in diesem video fängt
tatsächlich damit an dass sie sich jetzt
frühstück macht und diese plastikgabel
ist ein gipfel wie gesagt haben ja
gesagt eine mischung aus gabel und
löffel und sie lässt diesen
plastiklöffel ihr dabei zuschauen was
für eine kranke scheiße ist das sah hier
ist okay hier ist meine frühstück schale
und hier denke ich mal werde ich jetzt
ins rein machen weil ich hab voll bock
auf see ist also sagt leute das ist doch
nicht ist da nicht geistig normal oder
ist nicht normal dass man erst mit einem
stück plastikbesteck facetime und davor
einen großen vorteil hält dass das
verflucht ist und dass man die
verfluchte nummer von diesem stück
besteck irgendwo gefunden hatte und dann
baut man sich das nach ok und packt das
auch so ein kleines stück nähte als
basis und dann schaut es einen beim
frühstücken zu
nicht lustig und ich habe auch nicht
gedacht ich nicht so sagen
rebecca also berger ich weiß nicht wie
ich es dir sagen sollen ich werde auch
nicht so deine welt irgendwie zerstörend
eine alternative realität die wir
aufgebaut hast kaputt machen aber es ist
halt wirklich nur ein stück plastik dem
du so komische wackelaugen aufgeklebt
hast und es schaut auch nicht mehr zu
dir sonst schaut an dir vorbei also ich
muss sagen ich finde das ganze ein
bisschen blöd das klingt leute man kann
die sache drehen wenden wie man will es
ist nicht normal und es kann auch nicht
geistig gesund sein überhaupt sich das
vorzustellen oder so zu echten als wäre
es so nicht nur dass der lkw mit dem
gipfel redet nein sie fühlt sich auch
noch gleichzeitig von dem gipfel
verfolgt beobachtet und verfolgt kann es
sein dass für becker vielleicht wirklich
hilfe brauche ich noch machen heute ich
weiß nicht ob ich mit hockey zusammen zu
gehen
stopp stopp stopp also liebe rebecca bei
aller liebe nein macht es nicht die
geistige gesundheit der menschen in
deren stadt wohnt würde ich dir anraten
fuß lieber nicht weil ich glaube wenn
sie kleine kinder in so mcdonald's
setzen und sich nicht denken und dann
und dann läuft so eine junge frau so
mitte zwanzig wie du in den mcdonald's
rhein mit einer kamera und einer einem
plastikbeutel mit aufgeklebten augen und
redet mit dem ich glaub ich glaube dass
das für deutschlands jugend nicht so gut
ehrlich gesagt
sid hockey so aus als würde er hilfe
brauchen
[Musik]
hockey braucht hilfe das stück
plastikbesteck mit denen sie schon den
ganzen tag geredet und dessen zu dort
ging du dir zum ziel gemacht hast für
dieses video ja ich glaube das braucht
hilfe sonst braucht hier niemand hilfe
auf gar keinen fall
[Gelächter]
was soll man dazu noch sagen leute jetzt
sagt rebecca wegner mittagessen hier hat
sich eine pizza bestellt schneidet diese
pizza mit dem messer und redet weiterhin
fröhlich mit ihrem stück versteckt dass
sie mit wackelaugen und knete verziert
hat was ist das für eine welt in der wir
leben wir werden jetzt was ausprobieren
bevor ich weiter an dem video mache ich
mir probieren wir zwei apps aus und zwar
einmal ihr seht euch das wird nicht
wirklich besser im verlauf des videos
sowie können hat jetzt dazu entschieden
zwei apps zu benutzen um mit diesen apps
ihren gipfel zu untersuchen
ja wir kennen alle rostra da ist
natürlich eine sehr sehr bekannte und
weit verwendete app wird sich auch mit
einer der hauptgründe warum leute ein
iphone kaufen da jemand also klar
einerseits das design andererseits sowie
mahlzeit zu verbinden kann mit anderen
geräten und das dritte ist natürlich
dass das iphone besonders gut geeignet
das geister aufzuspüren
genau da wo vor key ist genau das hätte
ja auch hier irgendwo hin zeigen genau
dahin
in dem moment wo sie sagt so alter voll
krass dass geister radar zeigt genau in
die richtung in for peace verschwindet
einfach so der punkt und ist es einfach
nichts mehr da was soll geht es jetzt
weiter lesen video wird es der nächste
schritt
das sollten wir schon das abendessen
oder irgendwie so ein snack dazwischen
und ja sie legt einfach mit dem teil im
bett sie liegt mit diesem teil im bett
rebecca das ist kein normales
menschliches verhalten es tut mir leid
also will mit diesen videos wirklich
nicht persönlich angreifen aber normal
ist das nicht richtig dass da oben steht
messer das geöffnete steht einem
direkten messer gabel messer was das
könnte auch leicht missverstanden werden
okay okay
rebecca will nicht mit dem gipfel
schlafen mal zu nicht mit ihm in einem
bett schlafen oder ok ich denke wir
sollten froh sein dass es zumindest das
erspart bleibt jetzt doch ist er
wirklich kranke teil von diesem video
also mit bekkering wird mitten in der
nacht wach weil der gipfel geräusche
macht
[Musik]
und dann leute passiert das womit keiner
gerechnet hat lübecker ring stellt sich
ihren ängsten traut sich tatsächlich aus
dem bett aufzustehen und das ca 10 cm
großes stück plastik zu konfrontieren
und nach dem rechten zu schauen
[Musik]
neben dem zehn zentimeter großen stück
plastik es seien 20 cm großes stück
plastik auf gedacht scheiße man die bude
ist komplett verflucht
sollte also der wahnsinn im youtube
irrenhaus geht weiter wir fassen kurz
mal zusammen providing hat einen ganzen
tag mit einer plastikgabel ein
plastiklöffel an ihrer seite verbracht
hat diesen plasticker für ihr beim essen
zu schauen lassen beim schlafen zum
schauen lassen hat sich mit einer nacht
davon wecken lassen andere menschliche
lebewesen oder irgendwelche normale
menschliche kommunikation konnten wir
jetzt in diesem video nicht erkennen wo
becker inhalt ausschließlich mit einem
stück plastikbesteck geredet ja zur
beschreibung dieses videos passt dieser
screenshot hier tatsächlich ganz gut
also falls ihr euch sorgen gemacht habt
leute das bei rebecca ring
möglicherweise eine besserung
eingetreten ist kann ich euch beruhigen
das ist nicht der fall der scheiße ist
immer noch komplett geisteskrank also
werden wahrscheinlich auch noch in
zukunft einiges zu lachen haben ich habe
ich bis dahin nie einfach vorgestellt
ist wieder verlinkt hier oben könnte
meinen abonnieren das war's für heute
macht's gut ich größere augen und bis
zum nächsten mal